all right Simone is with us in San
Francisco hi Simone how are you hey Dave
I'm great how are you better than I
deserve how can I help okay so my
question was about going back to school
currently in social services I work for
the local county and I'm thinking about
getting a public administration degree
but I also like like tech support and
some type of IT fields which pay a
little a lot more so I didn't know if I
should you know to try a new direction
or stay in my current field where I have
over you know 10 years of experience and
you say about getting are in there come
up and so I just didn't know if it's too
late in the game to start over and try a
new path or or watch the average versus
the average person in today's world will
have 14 different jobs in their working
lifetime that's the average Wow and out
of that they'll usually have two or
three different careers and so um you
know we you want to use common sense
when you're selecting a career direction
and you're using that the way you're
discussing it I can tell meaning that
does it pay I mean you don't want to
just this thing of all finds your
passion well that's a bunch of crap
because your passion could be left
handed puppetry and there is no call for
that in the marketplace right so you
need to have a passion about something
that you can earn a living but you also
don't want to just go after money
because that'll get boring fast so it
needs to be something in a way you can
kind of test yourself on that is say
what if I woke up every morning for the
next 10 years doing X would I be it
would I be smiling when I went to work
and so if you moved in you know you know
what it's like to work in the
environment that you're in and if you
moved up in that environment in public
administration and you were
administrating some of the things that
you're working on right now and you in
other words you were in management or in
leadership due to having a degree in
that area is that going to make you
smile 10 years later when you get up
every morning and go to work if it does
then that may be a cool thing to do
if IT get you know get your juices
flowing and you want to go that way
that's fine
I've been doing this radio show 25 years
and I'm still not bored I still enjoy it
I still enjoy it I love what I do and I
tell the team all the time you better
hope I keep loving it because when I
stop loving I'm gonna quit you know so
that you need to have something that
kind of and sometimes if you just
something kind of sounds cool but if you
say ten years later I'm still getting up
every Monday and going and doing that
am I still smiling that kind of gives
you a gut check right I think I'm
nervous about wasting time with going up
in the public administration and then
getting up there and not liking it okay
I'm nervous about changing to ite and
saying wow this is more than I thought
or this or like you said this is boring
okay well the the I think you're
accurately assessing the public
administration is going to be a slower
trek through leadership and and you
already see some things in the way that
things are administered that are
frustrating to you and you're starting
to say gosh if I was stuck doing that
you're that's starting to bother you a
little bit the way you said that it
revealed that and now they and the thing
with IT is this as soon as you learn
something in the IT field
it's almost obsolete I mean you you you
have to be a to be successful in the IT
field you know in whether it's devote
web development or architecture or
whether you're working literally with
the hardware or whatever you're going to
do you have to be a continuous learner
and so as an employer I don't have any
public administration people on our team
because we're not in that in that space
obviously but but as an employer I've
got a bunch of tech folks on our team
from web developers to architects to
Ruby and you know Java all these
different things sis admins all these
different things are all through the
building here and the one thing that we
look for when we're hiring them is not
only do they currently have the skillset
but more importantly are they continuous
learners are they really reading and
growing and wanting to
classes and wanting to stay out there on
the bleeding cutting edge of it because
if not my technology is going to get
behind if I've got people here that are
stuck in five year ago mentalities
gotcha okay and one more thing of course
they've I have to say hello to my
youtube crazy families we love you and
we appreciate you taking our calls
absolutely well we love you guys we
appreciate you watching on YouTube and
hanging out the chatroom as well very
cool stuff Simone hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show you can do this you
know that really is a message whether
you've got two hundred seventy thousand
dollars in student loan debt or 27
thousand well you've got a fifty
thousand dollar income a five hundred
thousand dollar income